[Music]
on this saturday night intensifying its
offensive
the desperate search for survivors as
russia attacks cities in the east and
south and ukraine's president prepares
to meet with a key western ally
wildfire season erupts with a vengeance
as u.s states struggle to stay ahead of
fast-moving out-of-control flames
anglophone anger young quebecois
students
will pay the price for this the growing
pushback against a controversial quebec
bill
and the fierce fight to fill jobs good
talent has their pick in terms of their
employer the shifting power dynamic in
canada's labor market
global national
reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us it's
a rare showing from ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky speaking in person to
hundreds of journalists in an
underground train station in kiev the
president answered questions for more
than an hour as russia continued to
pound the front lines
zielinski told reporters he isn't afraid
to meet with russian president vladimir
putin he says he doesn't have the right
to be scared because the ukrainian
people have shown no fear zielinski also
confirmed the u.s secretaries of state
and defense will be in kiev tomorrow in
what will be the highest level visit by
american officials since the war began
it comes ahead of next week's meeting
with the u.n secretary general who'll
hold separate talks with zielinski and
putin and as western leaders try to
restart negotiations mixed messages from
inside the battle lines are emerging
mike delay has our top story tonight
new drone video has emerged from
chernikev a northern ukrainian city that
endured a russian siege for weeks
but just barely
in the southern city of mariupol more
shocking images as a few brave residents
were seen assessing what was left
russia says the strategically important
port city has fallen thanks to its
muslim chechen fighters who share this
video of their celebration
but gunfire can still be heard coming
from a steel complex where members of
the azop battalion are holed up
they're the group russia accuses of
being a neo-nazi organization an
allegation they say is russian
propaganda inside the steel plant women
and children remain hidden in
underground bunkers where food water and
hope are running out
i hope we can leave here and see the sun
says this boy because we've been here
for two months he may have to stay a
while longer because ukrainian leaders
now say the russians have reneged on
opening an evacuation corridor saturday
leading president of volor mirazlenski
to say if civilians are killed by
russian forces ukraine will stop
negotiating
meanwhile russia's stated plan to take
full control of southern ukraine is in
full swing he lost the main battle in
this war the battle for kiev so now he's
shifted missile strikes have hit odessa
apartment buildings killing at least
five people as the war enters its third
month
microlight global news toronto
an early and furious start to the
wildfire season at least 11 million
americans are under red flag warnings
tonight to be extremely careful as
fast-moving fires sweep through arizona
new mexico and colorado evacuation
orders have been issued for several
counties as firefighters battle flames
fueled by extreme winds jennifer johnson
has the latest
out-of-control wildfires are being
fueled by powerful and erratic winds
forecasted through this weekend for
arizona new mexico and colorado
the fires are spreading rapidly leaving
residents little time to leave their
homes you could hear the fire coming it
was so intense
the most destructive is the tunnel fire
near flagstaff arizona crews are
struggling to stay ahead of the blaze
which is only about three percent
contained the flames are destroying
virtually everything in their path
firefighters are understaffed and
outgunned by mother nature environment
is not very friendly
it was blowing 70 miles an hour climate
change has led to severe drought in the
u.s southwest the dry land coupled with
the high winds are preventing
firefighters from making much progress
basically these winds have been pushing
embers over those containment lines
landing in really dry brush creating new
spot fires families are desperate to
hold on to their homes or any belongings
they can grab before fleeing but with
the fire spreading so fast it's hard to
predict what neighborhood will be next
it just is really frightening to you
know think that just like that
it's gone dozens of structures have been
reduced to rubble firefighters are
trying to save what they can including
pets and farm animals
nice work
here we go this is an early and
devastating start to the year's fire
season already over 400 thousand
hectares have been lost nearly double
what was lost during the same time
period last year colorado's governor
fears this could be his state's worst
fire season ever these events are not
anomalies and that's why colorado really
needs to up our game to prepare for the
year-round fire risk that we now face
now states are grappling with the
reality that the wildfire season may be
year-round as thousands of firefighters
across the state battle nine different
major fires but until these winds die
down mother nature is winning the
battles
jennifer johnson global news washington
an intense search and rescue effort is
underway off the coast of japan after a
tour boat carrying 26 people went
missing in frigid and rough waters the
japanese coast guard says the boat
disappeared off northern japan after
issuing a distress call saying the
ship's bow had flooded and was beginning
to sink
waves in the area were reported to be up
to three meters high at the time police
have visited the sightseeing tour
company which owns the boat but no
details have been provided about those
on board
here at home the conservative leadership
race hit a key benchmark this week at
least eight candidates made the deadline
to file their paperwork and submit the
first installment of the three hundred
thousand dollar entry fee they'll need
to pay by the end of the month in order
to stay in the race on the west block
tomorrow david aiken is joined by two
leading lights in canada's conservative
movement former saskatchewan premier
brad wall and former cabinet minister
james moore to examine the health of
this race and the health of the party
david
well colleen neither brad wall nor james
moore have endorsed any candidate for
leader but both want to see the party
emerge from this contest in a stronger
position to compete for votes and
compete for power and they say party
members can help by picking a leader who
is not going to apologize for being a
conservative
there's a sense that many conservatives
especially those in the west went with
aaron o'toole and before him andrew
scheer in the belief that a watered-down
conservative would somehow translate
into more seats they did vote with the
party last time they stuck with it i
think for the most part
but i'm not sure that's the case now but
i think that's why you're seeing pierre
pollier get a good degree of support
because of the the energy that he's
bringing to the campaign and the way
that he's sort of being being
thoughtfully aggressive about being
proud to be conservative again
an ipsos poll published last week done
exclusively for global news found pierre
pauliab was clearly the favorite among
those who identified as conservative
voters but whether it's pauliev or
another candidate wahl believes the
winning formula for the next leader will
be a laser-like focus on the economy the
economy is going to be the number one
issue the economy that individual
canadians face in their household in
terms of budget in terms of
affordability questions and just
canada's overall economic health
and there is a sense among conservatives
that the next election could be theirs
to lose
now there's still a long way to go in
this race the vote is not until
september colleen all right david thank
you and you can catch the full segment
with former saskatchewan premier brad
wall and former cabinet minister james
moore tomorrow on the west block right
here on global
a battle is brewing in quebec over a
proposed language law that could force
college students to take three core
courses in french anglophone groups say
bill 96 would make many students fail
and potentially drive many out of the
province and spectre looks at the
growing pushback as the legislation
nears adoption
john mcmahon runs vanier college an
english c jeff with nearly 10 thousand
students after high school quebec
students go to c-jet before entering
university or the workforce lately
mcmahon's main focus is the fight
against quebec's new law bolstering the
protection of the french language
unfortunately
students young quebecois students
will pay the price for this bill 96 has
been working its way through the
legislative process for nearly a year
its premier francois lego's update to
bill 101 the law that prohibits
english-only signs and bans immigrants
from studying in english public schools
now lego wants to do more it's important
to understand that french
will always be in a vulnerable position
in north america
and we have to be careful
most quebec anglos have no issue with
preserving french culture but many feel
the bill goes too far it's really a
hammer
being used to swat a flaw
one recent amendment targeting english
cgip students has the entire english
school network preparing for war the
provision would force english-speaking
students to take three of their core
courses in french and while anglos all
learned french in high school there is a
difference between
french as a second language and learning
in french as the language of instruction
a significant number would either
experience lower grades than they
normally would if they were studying in
their mother tongue
or they may have difficulty even passing
the courses that could mean trouble
getting into university cadell thinks
many will just choose to leave for other
provinces if they go elsewhere they
won't come back they won't improve their
french and they won't become integrated
into quebec society so it's a complete
loss it's a lost loss situation for
everybody the amendment was initially
proposed by the quebec liberal party
which is usually where most anglophones
park their vote provincially after the
backlash their leader admitted it was a
mistake but many are now questioning
their allegiances to the party which was
already lagging in the polls making
things worse for the liberals a new
party called movement quebec has just
emerged it is against bill 96 we want to
be a party that represents montrealers
here at the national assembly mcmahon is
among several prominent anglophones
working to plan a protest in may i'm
hopeful that the the sense of fairness
the sense of justice will prevail
dan specter global news montreal
coming up in the equivalent of a buyer's
market for jobs what employers are now
having to do to hire
and the alberta program that gets
surgery patients on their feet faster
so you're gonna add to that twenty six
thousand did you bet a lot wow eight
thousand dollars look at that thirty
four thousand dollars more for you today
mateo roach has won her 14th game of
jeopardy becoming the first canadian to
win that many games in a row the 23 year
old has now racked up more than 407
thousand dollars canadian she's also
earned a spot in the jeopardy record
books placing number eight on the
all-time consecutive games list
roach who is from nova scotia but now
lives in toronto will return to the show
next week
roach isn't the only one on a tear right
now the job market in canada is red hot
and it's causing a power shift
there are about a million openings
across the country and just about the
same number of people looking for jobs
companies are now being forced to offer
more than just a paycheck to attract
workers and gaviola has more on the
battle for talent and
in this ultra-competitive labor market
employers are realizing they need to be
more flexible and offer job seekers more
choice
works in sales a year ago when he was
looking for a job he applied for
positions and got no response the market
was so competitive at the time with many
people looking for a job but not that
many openings it was really tough to to
find the right fit washer irc full size
he ended up landing a job as a sales
associate seven months ago at
vancouver's west group he was looking
for a good work-life balance and found
it here we have set hours and we aren't
expected to be available during outside
of our work hours which normally in the
real estate industry are kind of
available all the time so in that sense
you know you really get a chance to step
back from work enjoy the rest of your
life now with the demand for workers
he's being contacted by those employers
who didn't respond to his job
applications a year ago recently i've
had some of those same positions i
applied for now reach out to me
to see if i was still interested in
pursuing that opportunity i think
good talent has their pick in terms of
their employer and we are well aware of
that
hi come on in this shift in the power
dynamic with employees is making
companies look at different ways to find
and keep talent
providing the option to work from home
hours that are more flexible and other
benefits like gym memberships and
healthy lunches it also means changing
the traditional ways of how hiring is
done scotiabank has set up satellite
offices and removed the resume
requirements for some hires instead of
resumes it's using a 25-minute survey
developed by a recruiting company if you
look at the data that's in resumes
it's full of systemic barriers and
biases that dictate access to education
access to even internships or how fast
somebody's progressed in their career
you can line up a hundred people and say
okay these people tomorrow would be
eligible they could do the job but it
won't tell you who out of those hundred
people will actually perform well be a
top performer
enjoy the work
in what's being called the war for
talent hr and recruitment experts say
innovation in hiring is critical during
this transformation of the job market
colleen and gaviola in toronto and thank
you
and you can catch anne's full story on
how companies are luring top talent in
this hot job market tonight on the new
reality right here on global faster
recoveries ahead the alberta program
that's setting a new world standard in
care
alberta is leading the world in a
program that gets surgery patients back
on their feet faster along with reducing
hospitalization time experts say the
program could also cut costs and pain
medication use for patients as su lingo
reports it's also freeing up precious
bed space during the pandemic
when linda poissant had ovarian cancer
surgery in calgary last year she was
told recovery would be at least 10 days
in hospital instead she was out in five
i was eating
i was walking my pain was well
controlled so was my nausea i definitely
said i'm ready i'm ready to go home
linda was part of eras the enhanced
recovery after surgery program contrary
to standard protocols she was encouraged
to eat a bit before her procedure then
eat and walk shortly after she also had
minimal narcotics and a warming gown
like this one before and during surgery
i was just warm that air is blowing in
through the gown and it was in it was
great we know that patients who
have temperatures less than 36 degrees
you know for a significant period of
time during surgery are actually more
prone to complications dr greg nelson
says the program challenges some
historical surgical practices like
fasting which have little evidence to
support them there have been skeptics
there have been some surgeons
anesthesiologists who might have been
reluctant to adopt this but you know
the answer is really in
the outcomes among five surgery types
nearly 7 000 patients spent an average
of nearly one day less in hospital and
had about 16 percent fewer readmissions
for those that were readmitted their
stay was close to two days shorter eras
has saved the health care system more
than 34 million dollars for every dollar
that we've invested in eras in the
province we've actually seen 7.3 dollars
in return the program has also freed up
precious bed space about 10 years ago
linda had a smaller surgery and stayed
in the hospital for two weeks
this was
much
larger surgery
and within a few hours i was up and
walking on my own so they're doing
something right
giving away the profits the bc thrift
store owner whose bottom line is
kindness next
the toronto raptors have kept their
playoff run alive after a much needed
win over the philadelphia 76ers the team
delivered in a do or die game four at
scotiabank arena this afternoon leaving
the series at three games to one for the
visiting sixers and there was some
additional good news for canada's team
today raptors forward scottie barnes was
named nba rookie of the year before the
game making him the first raptor to win
the honor since vince carter did back in
1999.
a thrift store in british columbia is
making a name for itself not necessarily
for what it sells but for how it's
helping the community it relies on in
just four years the owner of denny's
dynamite deals has donated tens of
thousands of dollars to local schools
and charities kylie stanton explains why
step inside and try to take it all in oh
my golly there's all kinds of good
things clocks sporting equipment art
clothing stuff for the kitchen stuff for
my shop all of it at one time one man's
trash
thank you my dear now this man's
treasure nothing was planned it just
happened and now we've got a place
that's just turning into a great
community dennis bazzo bought this old
grocery store in nanaimo's harwood
neighborhood back in 2018. he had
retired had time on his hands and an
idea i do not want money to grow this
store roughly 90 percent of the
inventory at denny's dynamite deals is
donated by nanaimo residents while bizzo
buys the rest at local garage sales
but what's perhaps even more interesting
than the items he's collected is what
he's managing to do with it it's grown
and the money going out has grown with
it in less than four years bizzo has
simply given away roughly 180 thousand
dollars in merchandise i try to do two
hundred dollars a day
that goes out the door free it's for
people that really need it
and i have a good sense for that another
140 000 has been donated to local
charities and schools two weeks ago we
were the recipients of fourteen thousand
dollars
fourteen thousand dollars it's amazing
it's really a message of hope and um and
community and generosity and that's what
keeps people coming back since word's
gotten out about what denny does in the
community
the community supports the store with so
many great donations wherever he knew
there was a need he would
help it's just wonderful for bizzo it's
just a matter of looking at things a
little differently seeing the value
where others might not and perhaps
opening some hearts and minds along the
way it isn't about the almighty dollar
and that's what makes it special kylie
stanton global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada the seaside cliffs
in leading tickles newfoundland and
labrador we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you